hello everyone and welcome to the season
finale episode eight of podly the
official peacemaker companion podcast
brought to you by hbo max and dc
guys this is the last episode the season
finale and it's gonna be a real barn
burner we've got action we've got
fatherly hallucinations
and also broken legs so we've got no
time to waste yeah and as promised james
gunn is back for the final episode to
close out strong so we can finally ask
him
what this whole season was all about all
right you're not gonna want to miss this
yeah so uh
for the last time
let's get into it why is there a bald
eagle in your car that's equal eagerly
is your pet eagle yeah
is your dog named doggy
all right do you have a daughter named
daughtery
[Applause]
how's it going i'm iffy waddy way and
i'm your other host fiona nova and this
is podly the official peacemaker
companion podcast from hbo max and dc
and this one is it it is the season
finale there's so much to talk about so
much went down but before we jump into
it i have to always remind you
that this is a companion podcast for
episode 8 and most importantly
the the finale so if you have not
watched yet
pause go watch it and come back because
there are a lot of spoilers and if you
haven't even started yet go all the way
back because we don't want to spoil
anything for you it all comes down to
this so let's talk about it
[Music]
we've got so many things that happen uh
yeah i mean first off you have adebayo
trying to make things right you know her
whole spot was kind of blown up she kind
of feels bad about for sure she i don't
even think she kind of feels bad she
feels bad yeah and i think she's been
feeling bad since like episode one i
don't think she's gotten better yeah but
now she's really feeling the
consequences of losing the trust of
peacemaker and really manipulating him
something that you know she even
mentioned back when she manipulated uh
vigilante to go into the prison
she doesn't like doing that
but while she's trying to apologize
she's starting to
she's
yeah yeah there it is
yeah that's what happened and it's very
annoying
i know i'm the last person that you want
to hear from right now chris and i can't
i can't apologize enough
i really am sorry i'm just trying to
[Music]
[Applause]
what are you gonna say
this is a bit and he will run with it
and he will not stop yeah
yeah so adebayo is feeling the guilt
peacemaker is making her feel bad and
he's gonna run with it he's gonna keep
running with it adebayo calls her mom
yeah so and her mom and she says calls
like call like the justice league or
something
and the message is relayed but we that's
kind of all we hear and we're like okay
okay so back to the story got like a
helmet line it's kind of like that
chekhov's gun i was mentioning a few
episodes ago where
you have all these different helmets we
know they do different things so of
course for the finale they're gonna whip
them all out so we can see what most of
it does yeah and uh yeah well we are
about they are about to use the sonic
boom helmet for this
sonic boom
barn plant let's not forget the
anti-gravity
right the anti-gravity
we never really understood how this
power works how does it activate with um
peacemaker's voice does it activate with
just like white dragon's voice there's
no activation but now we can see that i
guess anyone can activate the helmets
yeah and then we have another important
moment we've wondered if eagley is can
actually understand and the whole
mission starts to ride on eagley
carrying the sonic boom helmet close
enough dropping it on top of the barn so
they can use it
that's right i need you
to take that helmet
and drop it on top of that barn
no eagerly no you can hold it take the
helmet eagley take the house eagley take
the helmet good england good good
so confirmed eagly has no idea what
anyone's saying yeah he's kind of just
like a dog
he senses feelings more so than language
so now they got to find the helmet
because their whole plan kind of hinges
on this and can never go smoothly yeah
yeah of course i mean that's what makes
a good plan but that's when we see uh
something harrowing you know his dad is
back his dad is kind of haunting him in
his in his head and it seems like even
though he's killed his father on the
physical plane he still has his father
inside yeah message and obviously like
it isn't him but it is real to
peacemaker so yeah but he did the right
thing and he like killed him in his head
yeah you know and i hope hopefully he
just keeps on doing that but yeah so
that happens they find the helmet right
where the needle was shot and the plans
back on they're good to go but now the
new plan is economos going undercover to
uh
to be like a security guard to drop the
bag yeah with the helmet in it
underground but we get like a deep
moment here on his like on his way back
up when he stopped
and they asked him about the dyed beard
we find out a lot about economists we
find out that he's never had a
girlfriend and that he thought that the
dyeing his beer would make him more
approachable and have friends and then
it gets even more heart-wrenching when
you see peacemaker hearing this
and for the first time ever it seems
like he's learning
period his learning period and also that
he's like understanding people's
feelings like he can hurt other people's
feelings and he needs to be more
empathetic it almost feels like it
happens because he himself had to go
through that with uh at a bio you know
like he's he's like feeling the pain of
betrayal with that now he's kind of
realizing that actions and things you do
have consequences beyond like what you
surface lover perceive you know can we
go back to that moment when he did drop
the bag he actually just dropped the bag
yeah
oh
no
oh
[ __ ] it
no more kindreds
yeah so then there's this after there is
this massacre of butterflies because
they keep using the sonic boom but
another thing we learned about the
helmet there's charges it seems yeah it
needs to recharge oh yeah and so so
they're just going toe-to-toe
big fight you know you got harcourt and
vigilante fighting i mean they're
fighting they're really doing their
damnedest they're fighting but then they
get there are so many there's so many
there's so many there's so many and they
can't obviously they fight as much as
they can and the fight scene was really
cool it's like a little slow motion like
you see the the moves that everyone's
making
yeah it was a fight and a bio comes into
the rescue yeah just right
and that was i mean like it was real
cool to see adebayo get like a full
action piece like that absolutely
because she went from the the person who
was just like really meek and afraid to
do any of this and she's coming out
double double double
busting it out you know because at the
end of the day if she is amanda waller's
daughter there has to be some kind of
fight yeah it doesn't matter yeah a man
would not have sent her if she didn't
think exactly
exactly and then then it comes down to
the moment they reunite
they find john cena uh adebayo tries to
torpedo fails
they capture peacemaker they go inside
it's sophie so sophie essentially is
like grabs peacemaker has him by the
neck essentially and is saying like hey
i we don't need to fight let me explain
to you what we're doing here and now we
get the deep dive into what the
butterflies are what their mission was
yeah so we find out that the mission
wasn't necessarily an invasion i mean it
was an invasion but not the kind that it
was perceived as like a takeover right
they just wanted to take over
leaders specifically because they saw
the human race moving in the same way
that their race moved that destroyed
their own planet so they were just going
to be our gentle overlords to help us
not help guide us yeah to not have their
fate
and this is interesting because like you
know they said you know we want world
peace just like you
this whole season that's all peacemaker
said he said he will get peace no matter
how many women children or men he has to
kill to get it and they have the same
ethos
but it's not enough it's not enough it's
not enough for peacemaking he's like no
he goes ahead and says torpedo activate
torpedo and autobio flies into the cow
he dispatches sophie which now goth
is re released
which was interesting yeah because
at this point we know peacemaker knows
that goth was gonna be free yeah but
he's not worried about that yeah yeah he
goes to help adebayo and he kind of
doesn't have to worry because their food
source is dead yeah they will know they
will eventually kind of just wipe out
wipe out yeah peacemaker seems like he
seems confident in his like decision and
not really caring yeah i think he's i
think we're good and so he carries
adebayo out and then we get this scene
yeah i mean the justice league oh my god
yeah yeah you can't miss it you can't
miss that we get the scene that really
is a spoiler yeah it's it's a major
scene you know the justice league
interacting with peacemaker in this
universe it's a cohesive universe and
you get peacemaker to finally have his
moment to tell the justice league uh
[ __ ] off yeah
you're too late you're too late i
already did it
yeah and i think he definitely felt good
about himself oh yeah because you can
always see that i feel like i i bet
peacemaker really wish he was part of
that crew i feel like he was she wasn't
at that pedestal or at that level that's
all he wants but i think he felt really
good being like hey i fixed this yeah
you could do better he really is because
remember how excited he got when someone
recognized him and then definitely was
like yeah you're you're a whack job yeah
you know so yeah he really kind of felt
some type of way about them and so him
getting to be like you know go out of
here and tell aquaman go [ __ ] some [ __ ]
yeah yeah so yeah and then we all end up
in the hospital because everyone is
essentially broken or dying yeah so uh
and and i think this is very it's very
sentimental because vigilante as as as
much of an idiot he could be he really
he he's like beat up yeah the guy speed
up and he was still standing yeah and he
was trying so hard
but he eventually just couldn't handle
it
passed out we've got harcourt who's
really injured like i mean she was shot
essentially she's really injured will
she even make it i mean she does but
like barely mm-hmm um everyone's hurt
we've got five days took her five days
and guess who was waiting for those five
days peacemaker the guy was waiting for
her wanted to know if she was okay and i
think harcourt at that moment realized
like hey this guy really does care for
me and um and i think is going to open
up a little more yeah but we also just
do we do see like this road to recovery
yeah
especially because it's recovery in a
big way because adebayo goes forward on
the press conference and blows up
project x yes talks about what it is and
we get another viola davis cameo
we always we love we love those cameras
yeah but i i think like at least when i
was watching it i was like oh gosh this
is big because not only is it affecting
let's say the peacemaker show yeah it's
affecting suicide squad yeah yeah you
know that's so who knows what the
repercussions of that motion is going to
absolutely lead to that
major it's major so we've got
essentially without trying i mean we can
always try to figure out like what might
season
two be or what would you know but it
seems like there's a lot of
ways this can go oh 100 because it has
that somber final scene where you see
peacemaker sitting next to the spirit of
his dad
and goff drinking the last up and you
can even in the poor there wasn't that
much of a nectar left
and it's and he's just staring off and
eagerly kind of drops by and it's kind
of like well what's next and we can sit
here and try and ponder what's next or
we can pester the writer and director of
the show james gunn and shake that
information out absolutely yeah so let's
go ahead and head to this interview yeah
yeah
[Music]
we are joined again today but with the
beautiful amazing james gunn the the
creator and just amazing artiste
of the century that's the century
i feel like that's a good season it's a
good season
because if she was like we're back again
with james
no i added on to the compliments you
have to keep going
well listen we've got some of a bunch of
questions for you since it is episode
eight it is the final episode and we can
talk about whatever and anything oh yeah
so
i want to know like one of the fun
things about this show is that
peacemaker and the gang go from like
keystone cops while like while planning
their attacks of badass
action heroes in the moment is
is comedy the most fun to write for you
or like or direct i i like writing
comedy i hate directing and editing
comedy it's it's the hardest of all of
them i love action is the most fun for
me overall because it's just it's very
much like putting a puzzle together and
um it's it's a much more of a right
brain activity in certain ways you're
not relying relying on the muse for it
comedy is harder i always have a very
specific thing in my brain of how the
actors are supposed to say something how
they're supposed to do it and it's just
like trying to make force things and
oftentimes through editing jerry rigging
and putting you know elmer's glue and
popsicles together to create what i what
i think is funny peacemaker the comedy
was probably came easier and was more
fun than anything i've done simply
because i have a very intimate
relationship with three of the leads uh
with with uh with john cena with with uh
amelia heart with the you know jennifer
holland and uh steve aj who's been one
of my best friends for 10 years so it
made it that gave me a real center to
kind of structure that together and then
getting to know freddy and uh danielle
and
chuck
who's gone on to have a big role in
guardians vol 3 is you know it just is a
great great team of people to
create stuff that's funny and then the
dramatic stuff that that comes along and
i i think one of the fun things about
carving the season out is letting us
just push that
sad element you know a little bit more
the the element the dramatic elements
the relationship between harcourt and
peacemaker the relationship between uh
adabio and peacemaker
and see where those things go in a
deeper way and in a much deeper way than
it could do in a movie because in a
movie you're so limited but in a tv show
you know we have uh eight episodes to
craft these really intimate
relationships that have a lot of nuances
and things to them and that that made it
really fun it looked like it was fun and
you know i got to speak with steve and
it's so funny uh
because
you know
steve i didn't know his comedy from when
i was in high school because i was in
comedy sports high school league and
then that's when i actually made him
feel old because i was like you were the
advisor of my he doesn't need to he is
old he doesn't need to feel like he is
yeah he said there was a point when he
was on set and he looked around he was
like i'm the oldest one here
that wasn't exactly true because i was
definitely there so yeah
so like i we were talking about how like
you know with with steven economist like
you
he had this like
deep moment in this episode where he got
to be very dramatic and serious and to
me like as a comedy dork myself like you
know it's very easy to be like the goofy
guy the comedy guy and to finally see
like a comedy guy get a moment to like
show his range yeah he would you know it
was it was a difficult scene to craft
because
steve was so good in that moment it was
how emotional do we go
because he's trying to hide himself from
the butterflies but he's also being
honest about something for the first
time and he's backed into a corner where
the only you know he's lied about this
for eight episodes about having dyed his
beer and even though we can all see that
it's clearly died
about having died his beard and now we
he's backed into a corner and he knows
the only chance he has for survival is
to be completely honest and uh and we
get this incredibly
beautiful moment that's as much about
him
as it is about peacemaker who kind of
sees the repercussions of being such a
dick like he is a dick like uh he's
always been a bully you know and um and
him being able to see like the
repercussions of this guy who he's come
to really cherish and seeing how he's
hurt his feelings to give that character
who's kind of the comedic sidekick that
deep moment you know is uh it was a lot
of a lot of uh very gratifying you know
um so and that this episode was fun in a
lot of ways to to shoot because of that
and give these characters not a wrap-up
because they all have a long way to go
but get those little glimpses of things
where we see you know harcourt's moment
of tenderness at the end is one of the
things that always moves me the most
because she's just been somebody who's
just pushed people away a hundred
percent yes no trust of anyone and the
moment when when when uh peacemaker
comes into the hospital room and she
realizes this guy
who she thinks of as a goofball
has been waiting outside for her for
five days to see if she lives or not
i think she experiences a kind of love
that she hasn't before and that's a
beautiful moment to see and then of
course the friendship between adebayo
and peacemaker which we see come to
fruition here and we see really the
story that's being told the whole season
this is about peacemakers ideals about
you know peace at any cost no matter how
many women or children
and then he's faced with this choice at
the end definitely making the right
choice from a personal perspective
where he's admitting
that he loves
other people
and his ideals are less important than
those people that he loves
and for him that's a complete change
from who we saw um in the movie the
suicide squad and it's been the thing
that he's been struggling with
throughout that all of a sudden he's
going you know he says it and i think
that the the second episode two he goes
maybe i'm just a maniac you know maybe
i'm just crazy
and i think he's starting to realize
that yeah there is a part of what he
does that is just he's just a a maniac
um and part of what he does is what
bloodsport accuses him of doing in the
beginning of the suicide squad is it's
he's using his ideals as a an excuse for
his own violent ways um
and what his father taught the way that
his father taught him to be adebayo and
peacemaker they both have these like
overbearing parents with strong ideals
so they already have that kindredness
that they don't that's right
where like like
to be honest amanda waller is not too
different she's like look as long as the
job gets done it doesn't matter what it
takes and i think she's work i mean you
know the amanda waller you know at least
in the suicide squad squad amanda waller
is a pretty hardcore individual i i mean
i think of amanda waller as the
antagonist of suicide oh yeah it's not
starro it's not the generals and corrido
multis it's amanda waller i think amanda
waller's ambition is a big part of what
she does his dad's work his dad's the
worst of all yeah he's the worst
character i think i've ever written
whereas with peacemaker i think he's
violent and he's a brute
um but i don't think he's ambitious i
think he's uh like he believes he's
doing the right thing even though he may
be fooling himself into believing that
he believes that he is where he's like
yeah he his he has shitty ideals and he
sticks to him but it's because he thinks
he's doing what right because he dealt
with a traumatic experience and the way
that he chose to deal with it uh was not
therapy it was sticking to these ideals
to make sure he doesn't make a mistake
like that again that that well i think
that's exactly right i mean i think that
one of the things that that happens to
us you know when we experience childhood
trauma which all of my movies are in tv
shows are about at the end of the day is
that he needs something to control
what he feels
he killed his own brother by accident
100
but he thinks that somehow through him
making this promise he can control
life around him which adebayo says to
him at the beginning of this episode
where she says you know you can't
stop death from being meaningless
just because you've made this vow this
episode and the change here is
part of his growth as a human being and
that everybody isn't who we thought they
were from the beginning of of the show
and uh and it makes it hopefully uh fun
for discussion because of that
yeah and so without giving anything away
what's what's next for a peacemaker in
the gang well i i think there's there's
changes of foot i mean listen i think
that the the sort of the bitter moment
at the very end of the episode is is
very very telling which is
he's killed his father
but his father is still there the voice
of his father that he carries around
with him and so how is peacemaker going
to deal with that you know how is
adebayo going to deal with the
repercussions of what she did at the end
of the show with amanda waller i mean
she betrayed her own mother and her
mother is you know you know she'll do
anything to to save herself really you
know and so what's going to happen there
what's going to happen with you know you
know economos is back with waller
obviously at the end of the show there's
a sadness there um vigilante is the one
character who remains unchanged from
start to finish he's the same [ __ ] he
always was and what's going to happen
between harcourt and peace may
peacemaker i mean is that more than
friendship and is it even friendship you
know
um
so i think that we have all these
different characters and we need to see
where they're all going and and
hopefully
we can uh
make that an interesting experience for
people to continue to see these
characters whether it's in peacemaker uh
season two or other other shows i have a
suspicion that you can do it and very
well the as you've proven in season one
and i can talk about this
forever i could i mean i could go for
two three hours but
they're waving me down they're saying
it's time to bring this in for a landing
so you're hbo max overlords
we didn't even talk about the judge
didn't even talk about the justice
league you guys
you're right we didn't say it yeah we
didn't even even mention it we didn't
even mention it we didn't even mention
it we didn't mention it yeah we got to
talk about that should we talk about it
we have to
i feel like that must have been the
hardest ask of the season where were
they like sure were they like it was it
was a it was a real struggle
and now i made the justice league show
up and they're all together and they get
to uh they're they're there to save the
day obviously but peacemaker gets his
little momentum
of being the boss because he obviously
has a he has a deep deep deep
jealousy of legitimate superheroes
because he is after all a guy who lives
in a trailer park with an eagle and uh
and a
weapon that's compensating for something
awful yeah that's a little bit too big
all of these things that peacemaker says
about these guys i want you to know they
you know aquaman doesn't really [ __ ]
fish um
uh you know superman doesn't like to get
[ __ ] on uh
you know green arrow doesn't have a big
butthole in his brony costume he just
has a brony costume you know uh wonder
woman never i asked peacemaker from
across the room she was probably looking
at him because he had a stupid helmet on
you know so all these things are are in
in in uh in in peacemaker's brain we
should make that clear for everyone that
none of that is canon
um however batman is batman
if i do batman
i just hear the sounds of
the keyboards right now updating the
wikis they're like they're like oh no
we made a mistake we're gonna have to
chase all of this i'm gonna get a lot of
which but was it batfleck or battinson
which one faced fat might i'm not how
did this work i don't understand
i'm like i don't know i just made it up
somebody else's problem to deal with it
i'm the one who put batmite into the
world now it's their problem
all right now to wrap this guest
interview up
we've got some eagley mail and it's the
final of this season
[Music]
so we're gonna take a fan submitted
question and ask yep
what made peacemaker a better candidate
for his own show opposed to the other
suicide squad members that this is a
question he gets asked on twitter a lot
i did that
i think we kind of talked about it a
little bit in the first episode i mean i
think there was just more there to to
you know to to digest with peacemaker i
had a lot more i like seeing you know
[ __ ]
find something redeeming in their
personalities you know so i i like that
you know i like that with whether it's
you know bloodsport or rocket raccoon or
peacemaker i like finding the something
that that's something really beautiful
in the ugliness of this planet and i
think that by finding you know the best
in the worst people i think maybe that
helps to be sort of a guide for myself
in my own life of doing that with the
people around me you know but also
listen you know for whatever reason i
just felt inspired to do a peacemaker tv
show you know i just
i just wanted to do it and so dc came to
me and they said
if you can make a tv show about anybody
from the suicide squad who would it be
and it was like peacemaker i had already
thought about it so it was it was just
came naturally and covid was happening
at the time i had nothing to do i was
trapped at my house and so i wrote all
eight episodes
in two months
nothing ever changed that's amazing
that's what happened you know that was
just a year and a half ago or less yeah
that i started writing the show and now
it's out in the world it's it's an
amazing amazing occurrence for me to be
able to create something and then make
it so quickly and then have it out in
the world so quickly you know uh you
know i'm finishing guardians 3 which
started four years ago so it's uh it's
been really it's been a great journey
with a great group of people on you know
on both on the hbo max side on the dc
side and you guys which i appreciate you
guys doing this podcast for these eight
episodes i really do and uh and can't
wait to see you guys again on on on
season two yeah yeah let's do it thank
you for saying that yeah yeah
i i do appreciate you guys doing this
thanks so much for this oh of course
thank you
you are such a pleasure to talk to you
it's great knowing more about peacemaker
and everything so thank you for taking
the time out of your days
again bye
that was
our interview with james gunn that was a
blast i could have kept talking he is my
favorite person right now he's like i
could talk to him for hours what a great
guy oh yeah it was a good time
but you know if the interview ends you
know what begins it's time for the peace
prize
[Music]
part of me is a bit sad because it's the
last one yeah
i know but we're going out with a bang
and we gotta give it to it so i think
the award for the peace prize this week
is going to be the death to peace award
which is going to be the attack on the
barn i think that entire fight sequence
with them finally a team together
fighting and then there's the intro
music oh it's so good it was like the
fight with the intro music it was from
like rip like going back in a circle
we're back here and we're we're all
fighting for one thing and even though
they did take some l's
even though people were hurt yeah as
they were and they were shot at yeah
they still really succeeded and they
were able to get to become like be a
team yeah they finally were a team in
that moment and even had a theme song so
i think that's a well
well
prize absolutely i couldn't agree more
i'ma mix it up what because i want to
give out one more piece prize
i want to give an eagley hug out to the
community for supporting us these past
few weeks throughout all the episodes
i'm gonna give that eagley hug from us
to you i've been on twitter i've been on
facebook seeing all your favorite
moments y'all communicating with us and
i really appreciate it you know it's
been fun doing this hey this was great i
love hanging with this guy
this entire this entire uh podley
podcast was great and it was great doing
it with you so well so fun doing it with
you hey what's up it's solo iffy poppin
eatin here yet again with a little bonus
surprise before we get out of here and
close out this season of podly
look we have none other than the comic
artist writer publisher and chief
creative officer of dc jim lee
and he has a little message for all of
y'all
thank you so much for watching
peacemaker
taking a character from the page the
screen can be a challenge but james gunn
john cena and the entire creative team
knocked it out of the park
having an episodic show gave us the
opportunity to introduce new fans to a
beloved character and expand the lore by
creating a fun and heartfelt arc that
balanced the gruesome with the comedy
tv and comics are unique in that they
allow the evolution and reinvention of
characters to tell great complex and
satisfying stories over the course of
multiple episodes or issues
this show was a wonderful chance to see
peacemaker grow in a very funny and
sometimes disgusting way with a equally
cool cast of characters by his side
the show is about superheroes but it
tells very human stories about family
and where we come from like in
christopher smith and leota adebayo's
case and also who we want to be and
where we want to go
so thank you again and see you soon
thank you so much jim and all our guests
who's joined us this season for podly
let's get back to wrapping things up
oh man well i mean that was it guys this
was the season finale
of podly and also of peacemaker thank
you for watching and listening this has
been podly the official peacemaker
companion podcast from hbo max in dc
and
look
it doesn't have to stop here your dc
journey does not have to stop here all
you have to do is go to dc universe
infinite sign up and you can be ahead of
the curve by getting caught up on all dc
comics and reading along your favorite
stuff you know there's a a certain caped
crusader who's got a movie coming out
soon so you might want to be catching up
on that cool and hey if you want some
merchandise and some peacemaker
merchandise nonetheless check out
shop.dccomics.com for the latest drops
you're not gonna want to miss them yeah
so until the next time you see us
wherever you see us
keep the peace keep the peace
you